brian mental health has taken a major
hit since the start of the pandemic
stress and isolation have put many
people in overwhelming positions and
unfortunately
led to a disturbing spike in eating
disorders sasha loftis spoke with one
las vegas woman who struggled over the
last year
and she joins us now live in our
newsroom tonight with her story sasha
denise and brian the woman i spoke with
tonight say she wants those struggling
to know
they're not alone disorders like
anorexia and bulimia are dangerous and
delicate
and they can be brought on by traumatic
events
like covid19 now they can also bring
them back
in full force for those who suffer
it's so easy to negotiate with yourself
and talk yourself through
you know oh i'm just gonna i'm gonna end
this tomorrow courtney olsen shares the
daily struggle of dealing with an eating
disorder
encompasses and takes over your entire
train of thought and your entire
well-being
she's fought symptoms for years and
coveted 19 has brought on an entirely
new battle
from april to august was a super
difficult time i could see myself
becoming unhealthy in terms of
my thought patterns you know starting to
get back into that old behavior
and she's not alone the national eating
disorders association reported a
70 percent increase in calls for help in
2020
as millions deal with stress and
isolation there's been a certain uptick
in
across the board in all mental health
issues since cobit
and seems to be getting worse the longer
we're staying isolated
local psychiatrist dr timothy yeiter
says if you've fallen back to old
patterns
it's more important now than ever to ask
for help
take time to take care of you that's the
biggest thing i can say and
courtney wants anyone suffering to
remember it's okay
to not be okay if you're struggling
know that this too shall pass
and nothing is permanent
now courtney says that video
conferencing from home and
really staring at yourself on a screen
all day can also lead to
obsession over body image if you've been
struggling with an eating
disorder during this time you can call
the national eating disorders
association hotline at 1-800-931-2237
reporting live in the newsroom tonight
sasha loftis 8 news now